da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono vari j ed oggi siamo tornati
su file ex che era quel gioco bello
grosso
vi lascio al video buona visione
[Musica]
sembra mia nonna quando mi dice che devo
mangiare di più e va bene va bene ho
giocato al kit mario con lo stai
tranquillo allora è bene tanto ce la
faccio sempre per un minimo e l'ora
haven
ciao cioè kg a finestra per continuare
sempre con tasso secondo me adesso mi
sputa papa vegas per qualche motivo si è
proprio papà vegas quello di un mail a
penne game play don't stop play le more
file file file file file ei messaggi
subliminali per farmi fare il gameplay
suo gioco ok che posso farmi da
liposuzione e diventare così gli sta
piacendo il giorno vero famiglia non
vedono e sono contento non c'è niente di
peggio di qualcuno che ti parli degli
segreti da me piace quando qualcuno mi
parla di segreti so che ti piacciono i
film horror e thriller
pistol chiari brutto stronzo fammi
capire mi sta ispirando 6 di là nella
mia nel mio salotto e non ci vengo lì la
continua affari gameplay vi sono un vero
youtuber lo faccio per voi lo faccio
anche per te o cagato addosso dal rumore
nomi spunta l'insetto quello del blog
dell'altra volta i miei delle zampette
di merda
e lui che fai che mi sta facendo sto
frank non lo so io cazzo devo fare lega
non lo so ti va bene sei navy dvd ok
prendi i pop corn ci vogliamo finirla
non so bisogno di fare con mi spiega
cosa devo fare ma l'iniziale c'è un tubo
[Musica]
ci sono programmi che possono modificare
lo sfondo del desktop piazza passa per
saragozza e cambiatevi lo sfondo del
desktop pluri di maniaci che palle
questi giochi che ti prende un possesso
del computer ciò sempre l'ansia ogni
volta e ci gioca sta roba
[Musica]
certo ovviamente che palle aprire libri
perché lo devo fare non vado a scuola va
bene va bene apriamo 77 mio numero
infatti vedi che bello proprio contento
di fare questi gameplay ragazzi va bene
c'è veramente lo vedi lo vedi che cosa
vedo che usi garnier
cos'è che cazz i capelli di somme
notizia che se lo vedi non lo cosa vedo
la sorella me fa altro che pro gaming
non ho capito il senso però ok non cosa
vorrei vedere la libreria dietro il muro
sicura l'ho vista a posto a tube lo
scoiattolo tutto che ecco io non sono
affatto ok musik credo va beh va beh
questo lo decifrato sorella zio ragazzi
che qualcuno si prenda la briga di
decifrarli sta roba perché per l'amor di
dio non c'ho voglia visto il messaggio
di prima sicuramente ci rinnoverà gli
auguri di pasqua io te li faccio di
nuovo caro tanti auguri
continua a non capire il senso di tutto
questo
[Musica]
cosa cazzo dello slider man ma chrome e
raven fermati ma fermati cosa perché c'è
una lucciola nel cos'è sta roba
ma la mamma di del creatore di sto gioco
lo picchiava da piccolo domanda lecita
neanche neanche ci riesco a passarvi
raffigurati come farci aiuto o perfetto
qual è la pagina della mamma degli
haters non c'è obiezione
quest'espressione dando regala un'ora
che ciò che sta roba cos'è senso che i
campi rom di prima dove sono finiti
salvini ha fatto tutto cosa lenore alle
9 e mia sorella assorta ma pure non ti
permettere di nominare mia sorella klose
windows
osate vedo che hai fatto molte volte la
faccia sulla tastiera per scrivere
questo bel testo vadano a dubbi
non è strano non è strano non è strano
non esisti tu sei così strano tua madre
quella strana perché ogni volta un
mistero non capisco cosa minchia do
cliccare qua
hai altre libri nascono di melo perché
sarah non ci metto un ora a trovarle di
nuovo porca eva cosa puoi usanza
l'italiana insultare un toccasana sarà
che ci ho trovato un 8 noto nell'albero
wow
[Musica]
rappresenta il cuore di ghiaccio della
mia ex e quella è la mia ex
cosa stai cos'è cosa cazzo bellissimo
che sono i franza che ride non avevano
accesso breve e raven non lo vedi cosa
sempre il cazzo che me ne frega dovrei
vedere ma questo è senza volto della
città incantata ma com è perché c'è una
tipa da dietro alla mia sorella quella
cha sorella breve raven vieni da me no
oddio bella cravatta aziende rose lander
mcauley lei non ti ha mai amata hai
fallito lei nella mia scale giorno
e vabbè allora sei stronzo l'ultima in
coreano noh imperfetto lenore perché
tutti mi hanno milan e mia sorella che
parla mai
mia sorella ha un buco nell'occhio
ok sorella cambia occhiali rever raven
gioca al gioco
non sto già facendo zia non ti
preoccupare
[Musica]
o ok c'è una scritta canale rehn
credo di dovermi congratulare con te è
finito il gioco sono impressionato che
ce l'hai fatta così lontano lenore che
sarebbe una sorella avuto problemi a
convincermi che per te ne sarebbe valsa
la pena hai visto i segni hai fatto
attenzione si è riuscita a capire il
gioco un cazzo di tutto questo lenore
lei era forte molto forte non
fisicamente ovviamente ma mentalmente e
vi ricordo che quando l'ho staccato
l'occhio lei non ha neanche quasi urlato
prima che tu via del mostro voglio che
tu sappia che non è stato per marchionne
è stato facile per me è difficile tenere
qualcuno cosciente abbastanza per
parlarci insieme mentre lo tagli guarda
ke kazzo 10 lenore era da sola e lei è
morta da sola come sono morti la giovane
ragazza l'uomo con la cravatta e il
taglialegna a quello dello scoiattolo ok
a quelli e dai personaggi del gioco
capitolo anche tutti gli altri avevano
ricevuto il gioco ma tu sei stata la
prima a completarlo quindi ora sono
sposati o altre cose da fare e questo è
un regalo da parte mia per te con tanto
amore file punto ex
[Musica]
maietta ma che cazzo terronia nove
ragazzi bella musica
complimenti avrei solo una domanda dopo
tutto questo solo una ma dopo tutto
questo e mi ha [ __ ] desktop come
cazzo lo cambia ma dai ragazzi questa è
la fa il punto ex un gioco bello grosso
fantastico spero che sia piaciuto è
stato proprio bello giocarlo mi sono
sentito a mio agio fa chi è quindi
ragazzi sperabile sia piaciuto a seguire
ogni giorno al momento è un mi piace
anche la risorsa che come livio
descrizione insomma se non si fischia
temi ci vediamo il prossimo video bella
ragazzi
[Musica]